everyone
never given a talk in a mask before so
hopefully this is this is going well
it's hard to communicate
all the information but
okay so let's just recap where we left
off so uh part one
left off with the following picture of
first order methods so
if we have a function that we are trying
to optimize and it is strongly convex
and has smooth our lipsticks gradients
is smooth
then we have this upper bound given by
gradient descent this somewhat intuitive
method where we just simply go
orthogonal to the corn contours of our
level sets
and we also have this lower bound and
there's a gap here
on the order of the square root of the
condition number the condition number
being l over mu
and we see that for poorly conditioned
problems
this can make a huge difference so
the question when this lower bound was
presented in 1983 was can we close this
gap which algorithm would do that
so with that prompting uh the core
concepts we're going to cover for this
part of
the tutorial will be acceleration
uh and i'll be clear what i mean by that
randomized methods and mirror descent
so acceleration
pretty much starts off with this idea
proposed by poliak um which is called
this heavy ball method
this algorithm where
instead of just going in the direction
of the gradient or the negative gradient
i add this scaled previous history of my
iterates
um and
there was very much uh a nice gym or a
dynamical systems perspective to this so
we can think about
and and
poliak introduced this algorithm as an
effort to discretize the following ode
so we have some sort of
dynamical system
that's second order in time i take two
time derivatives so by double dot here
or by x dot i mean the time derivative
of my
position at time t
so he introduced this algorithm as a
discretization and argued that something
like this should be able to achieve the
lower bound
um and the idea is just if we observe
the motion of a system
traveling along this
trajectory
there's this it
mitigates the zigzag zagging that can
occur and he actually actually produced
some uh
some bounds that are settings for which
i think if you're strongly convexing you
start off near the minimizer you can
show like such an algorithm will achieve
uh this really nice property of getting
the skirt of the condition number
scaling
and so the ball the the trajectory of
the the picture looks a little bit like
this so
as we discuss gradient descent bounces
off these contours
but momentum you take
what is this gradient direction
as well as you consider the vector of
your previous history and you
take some sort of combination of them so
you're able to
mitigate this zigzagging motion
this of course though was hard to make
rigorous and so that same year
such a notion was made rigorous by uh
yuri nestroff
so
yuri nasra proposed a method that was
claimed to accelerate gradient descent
what does that mean
the basic idea is to wrap the gradient
distance sequence
in something which will improve its
performance so we have gradient descent
that has this nice invariance to the
step size so in both settings i just
need a
scaling of one over l
and if instead of just moving in that
direction i take again this combination
of
my previous history
i can get that one over the square root
of the condition
uh dependence on my convergence
and so we did this in both settings
actually so for the smooth case
you have this beta k given by this
interesting choice k minus 1 over k plus
2.
and in the strongly convex setting we
have a nice ratio of this condition
number here and so
after introducing it the question was
why this choice
why specifically this algorithm what is
the intuition behind that
and whenever you have mathematicians
seeking intuition you have a flood of
people offering their perspectives from
whatever community they come from and so
that indeed is what happened and has
been happening
um
so there's just a series of perspectives
as to why such
uh scaling should work and whether what
is the scope of this extending it in
various other settings
and i couldn't pretend to uh go through
all of these so
i'm just going to mention them here very
briefly
so there is again this dynamical
assistance perspective and this was made
a little bit more concrete by sue boyd
and candace i'll loop back to that one
in particular
there's the perspective
of a chebychev polynomial so if you have
a quadratic
then uh there's some nice intuition
based on how the eigenvalues are scaling
that you can actually show concretely
why excel or give intuition as to why
this would work
uh there's an sdp formulation formalized
by george
there's this linear coupling framework
by allan zoo there's geometric shrinkage
there's a lot of perspectives geometric
shrinkage being you have these bounding
ellipsoids that you you try and shrink
in an intuitive way
um and of course there are a lot of you
know frameworks to
to accelerate algorithms writ large so
it is not just gradient descent which
can be wrapped in a sequence and
accelerated so there are tons of
frameworks
um i'm going to
focus on a framework that i think will
be helpful when we think about how to
extend this concept in more abstract
spaces um so hopefully this will match
and
align well with what super will be
discussing for geodesic spaces
and this is also a framework that uh
has been useful for for accelerating
other algorithms so basically a template
for acceleration
or one template rather is that we couple
some kind of dual step
this will be mirrored a mirror descent
step and i'll discuss what that
algorithm is in in the next
segment
or the last segment
and some baseline algorithms a primal
step
and
there have been many many baseline
algorithms that have been accelerated so
we have gradient descent we have this
algorithm that i'll discuss at length
mirror descent
proximal gradient descent so we saw that
in the last session
cubic regularization of newton's method
that was also introduced uh
abstractly in the last session and there
are other techniques where you can use
higher order derivatives of your
function and create some sort of model
some sort of surrogate for it and just
simply minimize that and all of these
come with a specific rate of convergence
and just by wrapping it
in a uh
dual kind of coupling it with a dual
algorithm
a lot of these can their convergence
rates can be systematically improved in
certain settings
so there's a whole
industry and this is not exhaustive this
is just a
small snippet of what what's been going
on
um
so i'm going to
you know whenever you talk about
acceleration it becomes hard to not get
in the weeds
uh
i think i'm going to give you an
illustration that i hope will be helpful
again in the geodesic setting
um so i you know we have to get a little
bit more in the weeds so there's this
format for acceleration as three
sequences so here we have
a coupling step which consists of
performing some kind of convex
combination between a sequence z k and
xk
we have a gradient step
from yk
and then we have what i'm going to just
broadly refer to as a dual algorithm
taking some combination of the gradient
and the previous direction
that is another way of writing down that
two
sequence uh
accelerated gradient descent so we just
introduced an extra one this can be
collapsed of course
if you
stare at a lot of the proofs which are
very lengthy very very lengthy uh and
you try and look for the quantity that
is dissipating along the trajectory of
the algorithm it has this basic format
it's some scaling of the function or the
optimality gap plus some scaling of this
distance
and
basically what most proofs
do when they work from this perspective
of let's just write down something that
decreases is you start with
just arbitrary sequences ak and bk you
write down this difference
and then you use properties of the
algorithm as well as the function values
to try and get this dissipation property
satisfied
so if you do that
you will get some sort of relationship
between all these coefficients these
abstract coefficients and the the
coefficients for the energy function
so this construction that i'm
demonstrating was introduced by nesterov
in o4 and improved very recently
by anan shraw to try and get this
phenomenon working in the geodesic
setting
so here what's going on
is
if you try and bound this energy
you can do so
if you have the following update so it
looks a little bit complicated but we
can break this down into two steps so
and the first step you're solving some
sort of relationship here with our gamma
k sequence
based on what bk and ak is at the state
k
and then you use this gamma k
to update ak plus one and b k plus one
and then you use those two things to
update the parameters
that's just basically it
in
abstract terms so
it's highly algebraic
um
i don't know what more intuition i can
offer outside of that
but it's useful to see because uh
as i said this will be discussed again
okay so let's see why this gives us
these rates of convergence so let's look
at how a k plus 1 and b k plus 1 are
changing
so
i'm telling you that this sequence
ensures that we get our dissipation
property so we get e k plus 1 is less
than or equal to e k so we get this
decreasing
sequence so if i just simply write that
out
i get something that looks like ak
here let me
write down
so we get
a k over ak plus one
and now if you look at how it's being
updated
this is just simply
one minus gamma k
very similarly we can write down with b
k plus one
over a k plus 1 is
so i took this lyapunov kind of or
decreasing identity and just divided it
through by the coefficient scaling the
function value to get this down this
upper bound
and i'm just trying to understand
what the convergence rate is i can
conclude from what these values are
telling me in terms of gamma k so that's
why i'm going through this
so
if i look at b k plus one and how it's
also changing
i'll get one minus gamma k
times gamma k squared
times l
okay so i have some sort of sequence
that has one minus gamma k i can pull
out in front
there's an extra gamma k squared times l
scaling that distance function
but if that's
well behaved i can conclude a 1 minus
gamma k
rate of convergence at least the product
of them
and so
what uh su so what ana shraw showed is
that for any arbitrary value in this
starting value
this gamma k if you solve this equation
is actually converging at a geometric
rate to one over the condition number
if the condition number
is infinite so if you're not strongly
condensed anymore
then we can we can look what happens to
this sequence so if you have uh
and this term becomes zero
and then you look at how the b k is
being updated
b k plus one
is just simply going to be equal to b k
so the first equation is telling me
that gamma k squared over one minus
gamma k
is equal to b k
over l a k
and the second one is telling me that b
k plus 1
is equal to
gamma k squared over 1 minus gamma k
times l a k
so if i take this over here this is
equal to b k
so the gamma k's remain constant at the
initial value i start with
and also from this you can infer
that the gamma k's are evolving at a one
over k rate and a k is evolving at a one
over k squared rate so this gives you
kind of a it covers both settings i
could just write the accelerated
algorithm in this one format where all i
have to do is solve this recursive
equation
so hopefully this will be revisited soon
when we talk about geodesic spaces but i
think this construction is is nice to
see
and in the end what i can infer from
this then
is that i get this uh rate that scales
as the product of these one minus gamma
i's and of course gamma is converging to
one over the condition number so i can
start with any gamma and it will
converge
okay so that was a little bit uh
technical and it doesn't offer you much
intuition yes so
was this a new feature of this work to
actually get both of the the cases at
once like this was usually studied
separately so actually no nastrov showed
or in his 2004 book even you can get
both cases or even in his recent book
got both cases at one the new feature is
this
uh
initial starting point for gamma there
was a bound he placed on it and they got
rid of the band you can saw it from any
arbitrary gamma
yes
yes it should be smaller yes because it
converges upwards so yeah sorry about
that fishy go in this direction all of
these
are there any other questions about this
construction
so this you know typically when people
offer
coverage of multiple settings in one
algorithm it can be called universal or
adaptive to whatever the setting is so
this was the adaptively set uh
accelerated gradient descent
so let's get back to intuition um
i i kind of like thinking about this
this idea um
you can tell my favorite interpretation
is
this one offered by sue boyd and kendez
as
modeling a second order ode this is
poliak's early intuition just made a
little bit tighter
by introducing a specific ode and trying
to understand its properties so this is
a very beautiful paper i encourage you
to read it if you're at all interested
in the accelerated gradient phenomenon
but essentially
what they did is they took the
continuous time limit of the algorithm
and
showed that it can be said to model this
second order ode
so uh this is just one continuous time
limit there are multiple ways to go from
a discrete sequences to continuous time
but this ode has nice properties so they
use that to motivate the acceleration
phenomenon
so as i stated it's like taking gradient
descent and adding this acceleration
term
and this dissipating quantity which
scales as three over t and the
mysterious thing was
y three over t
why why this damping term they showed
that if you have two over t this
actually no longer
converges
uh it's what's called uh over damped
and then if you are or
larger than you are under damped
hopefully i got that right
so you get this kind of nice uh
scaling of of the damping term
but i think one of the nicer things
about this ode is they're they certified
that it itself is in continuous time
minimizing the objective function at a
one over t squared rate and they do this
by using a leaf and off function which
they introduce
and so there's this nice kind of
technology of
looking at these dissipating quantities
and continuous time and showing their
links to discrete time
i myself may have been involved in some
of this so i think
clearly this perspective is being
offered
here in this tutorial
um but i do think it does come up and
has been utilized in more abstract
settings
so
that's pretty much
what i wanted to cover acceleration will
kind of come back when we discuss
randomized methods which is our next
topic so i'm going to pause here
and take or just see if there are any
kind of questions
okay fantastic
i will move on and please stop me if you
have any
okay
so
these deterministic methods are really
nice but
generally speaking in machine learning
settings we are in this big data regime
where we're often tasked with minimizing
a function that has the form of this
sum
and when it is large it will become hard
to to compute full gradients
because we have to sum over all these f
i's
so there
are many
ideas for how do you actually uh perform
minimization but a lot of them are
basically
of the form
take a sample
from your sample space and then just
simply compute the an estimate of the
gradient direction using that sample
so if you use the full sample what you
get is full batch sgd or aka gradient
descent
um you can compute an element of the sub
gradient so this is
sub gradient descent
um and then the big idea
by robinson monroe in the 50s is just
sgd which is just compute the gradients
on that sample
so that's sgd and
the
trajectory you can see it can be quite
noisy
but each computation is significantly
less expensive
it will scale it'll be independent of in
whereas gd
scales linearly in n
that's the basic construction of sgd
perhaps the most popular method in
machine learning so let's get to
the theoretical side of this i can show
you many plots of sgd and there'll be a
plot or two but
what can we say about its performance in
the settings we've discussed so far
so
one thing
one classical result or set of results
about sgd is the following so if you
have
uh each fi has
is smooth so it has lift shift gradient
and if f the objective function is
strongly convex
then what you'll get is that the gap
between the function evaluated at what's
called this
polyacryl average iterate
and x-star will be in expectation
decaying as one over root k
in the convex setting and the condition
number over k in the strongly convex
setting
and notice that these step sizes are
different now so there's not this
invariance to both settings that we can
establish via the stuff size so we look
at these two rates they're significantly
worse than what we were uh getting
before so like one over root k is
a very very very slow rate of
convergence often in practice we we see
you know not that but nevertheless this
is the the
upper bound and
there are matching lower bounds so we
cannot do better than this
um but there is a big difference between
sgd and full gd so we have this one over
k difference and then one is decaying
linearly and one is just one over k so i
mean this is this is quite large
okay so
in rush the researchers how do we make
std better
what can we do
so the first strategy is just to revisit
a very classical idea i can accelerate
all sorts of algorithms why not just
accelerate sgd
um and so there have been uh several
authors who have looked at that and have
attempted to do that and by acceleration
of course i mean
the classical add this coupled sequence
and add this dual step
um but you know sgd saturates this lower
bound so what you're able to do
um is improve the initial convergence
but at the end of the day you get the
same sublinear rate for this dominating
noise term so you cannot
do much better using momentum that said
people do it in practice so if you
look at uh if you train a neural network
the heavy ball algorithm is is often
employed and
it often or sometimes does
have nice practical performance so
just because theoretically
it's not doing much doesn't mean that
it's not you know not worth using
the second strategy which i'll discuss a
little bit more at length is this idea
of variance reduction
so
there are many
methods for variance reduction i've just
added three i'll cite some more and it
will also be non-exhaustive because this
has just been a booming industry since i
think like 2012 so
hard to cover at all
but the basic idea
in a nutshell is we can perform lazy
gradient updates or at least
you know
enlarge our storage requirements store
all these previous gradients and utilize
that to get a systematically better rate
so what you'll classically see
is
scalings like this we'll
have each problem will depend on this on
the dimension
because we're computing
vectors of scale sd
we'll have this you know we have this
linear rate in this polynomial rate
but the big difference here is how the
dependence on n for each algorithm
so as i said sgd is independent of n
because it's just sampling one thing at
a time this is not batch std
gradient descent will have this
condition number scaled by in
and
these variance reduced methods very
classically have this dependence that
scales as in plus the condition number
so we kind of get this what they say is
the best of both worlds kind of
phenomenon
uh which is what happens when you do
this lasik gradient
update
so as i said there's this very big and
growing library of methods um
this is a non-exhaustive list i there
are way more um
but there's svrg zag visa finito sarah
saga
cca i mean
i couldn't cover them all and i think
you know people when they're talking
about more abstract spaces have made
attempts to bring these algorithms to
bear in these settings
the two algorithms i will discuss
because i want to give you some
intuition as to what's really going on
here is uh svrg and saga
so
svrg
this is one format of it there's a
double looped format of it so i'm just
gonna present this one so what's the
idea here
so
so the estimate i of the gradient that
i'm going to use
is going to be
the stochastic gradient at my sample
computed at the current iterate
so this would just be sgd but i'm also
going to be adding
the stochastic estimate computed at
another point w k
and then i'm going to also be
subtracting the gradient
at w k
so we can see that this is an unbiased x
this is an unbiased estimate for the
gradient at xk i take the expectation
these two terms
go away and i'm left with the
expectation of this because this an
expectation is equivalent to the
gradient
there should be no ik here
so an expectation i'm doing the right
thing this is an unbiased estimate
but the idea is this will hopefully have
less variance than if i just had sgd
so how does wk evolve how is wk selected
wk
will be equal to
xk
with probability 1 over n
so with very small probability
if w k is xk i'm computing a full
gradient
so an expectation
hopefully i'll be computing on the order
of
one or in gradients
with the remaining probability
so 1 minus 1 over n
it'll just remain the same so i'm doing
these lazy updates for this estimate
that in a nutshell is svrg
and there are nice complexity guarantees
that pretty much an expectation
match what you would get for the
deterministic setting across various
function classes
the proofs are a little bit more
involved so
i'm not going to go through them at
length today uh there are other things i
would like to highlight but this is the
basic intuition
saga is a little bit different what saga
is doing is it's going to be storing all
the previous gradients i had
i've accumulated and then just simply
updating certain parts of it as i go
along
so one has a very large memory required
requirement whereby i'm storing all my
previous gradients the other one
has a
much nicer memory requirement but i am
computing full gradients every now and
again and
so that
might be untenable if i don't ever want
to compute a gradient
okay so those are the two kind of
templates for how these variance
reduction techniques work that i wanted
to review today
and let's see how they perform in
practice you know it's hard to show
plots because you know
i can i can make a lot of plots that
look like a lot of things so
uh
hopefully this this plot does illustrate
though these methods do tend to work
well for for problems in certain regimes
typically convex problems where in is in
is a reasonable
um has a reasonable scaling
but the difference here could be
dramatic so this these two upper lines
are sgd and gradient descent
and saga is doing significantly better
so if we just upped our storage
requirements we can we do much much
better
that's where this best of both worlds
phenomena
or characterization kind of comes in
of course
these methods can also
be again accelerated most things can be
a lot of things can be accelerated so um
there are a lot of frameworks for doing
this uh catalyst is a really nice
framework that was introduced by lin
muriel
park chewie hopefully i pronounced that
right um
and and they use it to essentially give
accelerated versions of all these
methods so what does that mean what does
it mean to accelerate in this context
it means that i can go from
this dependence here which was
the condition number dependence to
a square root in times the condition
number dependence
so
in certain regimes this will behave much
much nicer and people have also
introduced frameworks coming from the
intuition that they brought to bear in
the deterministic settings their
estimate sequence frameworks we off and
off frameworks and what have you
um
and so again these these constructions
these proofs a lot of them look very
very similar to the deterministic
settings where where things are just
decaying in expectation
yes so it seems that
even though they're all using the same
article they all have different
constraints but if we just take maybe
the
intersection of all those setups right
which is okay they all like you know
somehow if i prove a lower bound for
this it's going to apply to all of them
is there a low bound that's established
that says for example that the root end
should be there in front of the key yes
yes there is indeed a lower bound for
the root in conditioning
um there's also
so so
this this version of things requires
actually each uh fi to be convex
uh
if it's non-convex it's what's called
the sum of non-convex problem that
dependence of root in decay
it scales us into the i think three over
four so there's
you have to be precise about which
regime you are in nevertheless there are
lower bounds for for each of these
problem settings um
and these accelerated versions you meet
the lower bounds so
cannot necessarily be improved
i'm going to show another plot of these
accelerated versions it comes from this
jiggs paper this
this last paper i'm citing
um so this is kind of what you'll often
see oh it's resolution is it's not great
the the plot is essentially saying that
so there's saga in the red here
and its acceleration version is in the
dotted and essentially we all have the
the thick lines are going to be the
non-accelerated versions and the dotted
are
the accelerated version and of course
across all these examples the dotted
line is below
the thick line so you'll see often plots
like this which is meant to indicate
that even in practice
uh adding these kinds of momentum based
frameworks to your descent
uh estimate is is
going to be helpful
if you of course know some of the
problem settings it can be also
disastrous
if you
have some mis-specifications there
i don't think it's necessarily worth
parsing uh which ones beat which ones in
which setting they're all pretty good
yes could you say a little this is new
to me could you say a little bit more
about an example of a misspecification
that could make this type of
acceleration yeah so
yes yes absolutely so a lot of these
methods will depend on knowing the
condition number
to determine the coefficients in front
of the algorithm if you do not know that
condition number
uh specifically if you underestimate it
you're you can diverge
um
and
you get also wild oscillatory behavior
they're restarting schemes to adapt to
this but it's um you do have to know
specifically those kinds of things in
the lipschitz concept as well to to make
sure your your plots behave like that
but of course you guys know the lips is
constant for gradient descent so
but it does uh there are papers which
indicate that uh gradient descent is way
more robust to noise
than than accelerated methods momentum
methods
way more stable to to noise
so sgd is still widely used and very
very popular in this stochastic setting
okay so the last topic i wanted to cover
it's hopefully going to be a really good
merging into what nikolas is going to
talk about which is romanian
romanian
optimization
and that's because mirror descent is a
very special structured case of that
and so
and it's also
has brought much benefit to to the
optimization landscape
so i'm going to introduce some core
concepts of manifolds but nicholas is
going to do a much much better job way
more detailed at a much slower pace
probably than than i will so i do want
to
preface that here that if this wasn't uh
the introduction you would like you're
about to get another one so hopefully by
the second round it'll have absorbed in
your your psyches here
okay
so let's start
um by introducing the concept of a
manifold very informally so
we say that a manifold
is a space which locally looks like our
city
so
maybe the picture to have in mind is a
sphere where
locally i'm standing here it looks flat
but globally it does
not um and so some
examples to have in the back of our
minds because they'll come up in the
context of mirror descent
uh is
this positive orthant
uh so this is the set of vectors in our
d whose components are positive
the
simplex
so
this is the set of vectors whose
components sum to one
this is widely used in the context of
probability
and the space of positive semi-definite
matrices
so these are matrices that are
pse at every point
uh x has a tangent space which is the
set of all tangent vectors at that point
and i guess my rendering of x looks a
little bit different than i had actually
but yes the tangent space is just a set
of directions i can move in a small
amount and still remain in that space
very informally speaking
so the tangent space of the positive
orthant is just all of our d
for the simplex
it's going to be the set of vectors that
sum to one so now why is that what's the
intuition for the tangent space
so informally
i want
to understand the set of directions
which remain in x for small t
so if i look at this
uh look at the sum i equals one to d of
this
for it to remain on the simplex this has
system two
one
i already know that this piece here
sums to 1 because x is on the simplex
so what this is telling me is that t
times the sum over these directions
equals 0 1 to d
has to be zero
for small t
and so what this means is that the sum
of these directions these directions
have to be zero so that's that condition
here
and so you kind of can informally derive
why these conditions are why why this
characterizes these tangent spaces
and so for this psd matrices the tangent
space is simply the set of symmetric
matrices
so every tangent space has a romanian
metric
this is a symmetric and positive
definite form
and it gives us a way to measure angles
on this tangent space between two
tangent vectors
and the reason why it's important to
think about this metrics in the context
of mirror descent is in this special
case
where x is a subset of our d
we can actually represent the metric by
a positive definite matrix
so
i can say that here we go all right
[Music]
so
this rendering of g x
d v becomes now
i'm going to say the norm of v
at x which is going to be the inner
product
of g of x
n
so i have this this now matrix which is
defining this norm on the tangent space
and the special case that we're going to
talk about in the context of mere
descent is what's called a hessian
manifold this is a manifold where the
metric
is given by the hessian of a strictly
convex function
so this g here is the hessian of a
strictly convex function
okay so why uh well so let's go through
some examples um and here i'm gonna ask
for your input uh
so
we have again this positive orphan where
we have this log determinate barrier
metric so it's going to be written as
the diagonal of 1 over the component
squared
so what is this the hashing of
yes
so it's the hessian of this log function
what about this fischer metric this
comes up all the time in on statistical
manifolds this is uh
very popular this is probably the
example to have in the back of your head
so what is this the hashing of
yes entropy that's great thank you
chip
and just by definition this is just uh
the the log determinant metric is the
action of the log deck so for psd
matrices this is a very nice metric to
place on your space
okay so i just need two more objects and
then i'll i'll have gotten i'll get to
the conclusion of of what is meredith
and what is some intuition we have for
mere descent so the first object is the
notion of a differential this is a
cotangent vector it's a linear
functional it's a mapping from the
tangent space to r and it gives the
directional derivative along any
direction v
so i can kind of write that out
explicitly as the inner product of the
gradient and v
so this is the definition of the
differential and if i have this
definition
in mind i can then define what is the
gradient
finally on my hessian manifold which is
the object i am after
so
the gradient of f at x is going to be
the tangent vector corresponding to this
differential so it's going to be the
tangent vector which makes these two
things equal
so on the left hand side
i think that space here
on the left hand side
actually let me
i have
d f the differential of exit v which
i've already told you is the inner
product of the gradient
at x and v
and on the right hand side i have this
this metric between the gradient of f
and v
which i can write as a matrix because i
am on a hessian manifold so this
gx
of
grad
x
and v is going to be
just
the inner product of
grad x times this gx
this is just transpose here
okay so i just need these terms to
match i need
this to match this for all d
and so from this i can actually conclude
what the gradient is
on on this on on manifolds that are
substance of rd in order for this to
match it must be the case
that this part is equal to the grad or
nabla f a set of partial derivatives
which means that my gradient is given by
the metric inverse times the gradient of
f
okay
fantastic
uh i've
explicitly written this out here
hopefully that intuition wasn't enough
for for deriving why this is the case
why do i scale the gradient by the
metric inverse
and so the gradient flow is just the
vector field chosen to be the negative
gradient direction so this is just going
to be this uh equations dynamical system
here where my time derivative of x t is
given by the negative gradient uh
direction so the metric inverse times
novel f
that's the gradient flow
okay fantastic so now we have
what the gradient flow is on a hessian
manifold
on a hessian manifold the gradient flow
is now given by the metric inverse sorry
the
the
inverse of the metric so this is the
hessian of h times the gradient
and so when discretized this is actually
an algorithm that does get used quite
often in practice called natural
gradient descent
um this was proposed by mari and i mean
actually this is pretty well known he's
i'm probably not the first person to
have proposed this but it's been very
very well studied
um
and is
you know the motivation of a lot of
other algorithms that try and
approximate this this gradient flow
okay so we have natural gradient descent
but what is mirror descent
uh so mirror descent is a special case
is something that happens when we map
our space to another space via a
bijected smooth map
so
let's say i have a space
x and i want to map
it to another space z
uh via a mapping
by
they qualify
um and it's bijective and smooth it's
got an inverse i'm going to call that
psi
so i have a gradient flow over here
some kind of curve it's not really it's
not squiggly but it's fine you can you
can pretend that's the gradient flow
there
and i can track how
this gradient flow
changes uh the push forward under this
mapping
so i can track how the function
transforms
how the gradient changes this is just
going to be given by the jacobian of
this inverse mapping times the function
applied to
that inverse
evaluated at z as well as how the
metrics changes so i have a metric on
this space g i want to look at the push
forward
metric
under this mapping
[Music]
mapping x to z via this phi map
so i have these three objects and with
that i can write down what the gradient
flow is on
on z
so the gradient flow is going to be
given by this equation and the key thing
here is we have this jacobian inverse
multiplying our metric
it becomes a little bit more complicated
if the jacobian isn't isn't nice in some
way
but something really nice happens when i
don't have this abstract mapping but i
have a mapping that is given by the
gradient of a strictly convex function
this is what's called a mirror map
and hopefully that'll motivate this
notion of mirror descent
um so i have the strictly convex
function i can define its legendre dual
via this
uh optimization problem here and this
this formulation this legendre dual
function has really nice properties so
even if h is not convex it's dual
function is
is convex
it's double dual is also convex so i can
take the dual of the dual
and i get a closed convex function
so this gives rise to differential young
inequality
but also
i can write down now what this metric is
so this metric is going to be the
the inverse of the hessian of this dual
function
the jacobian is just going to be this
partial derivative
applied to this mirror mapping so then
when we write that out that's going to
be
uh the hessian again of this dual
function
so now when i write up what the gradient
flow is
this jacobian and metric are going to
cancel each other
and what i get is this really nice
dynamical system in the dual space
so i got just z dot is equal to negative
grad f at x t
so that's
the motivation for some of the
terminology behind neurodescent it's a
descent flow in this dual space that's
what that abstractly means
um and so
uh well i haven't told you what mirror
descent is but now i hopefully will uh
so we have this dynamical system it's
given by
uh it's this gradient flow in the stool
space under this mirror map
um
and i can discretize this i can
distribute it in many ways but the most
basic thing i can do is what's called an
euler discretization
so i just simply
evaluate the vector field and there's
limited space
[Music]
erasing
so i just simply
approximate this vector field
via
a over eta let's say for small eta
so as ada goes to zero this is hopefully
a faithful approximation and then i
evaluate the vector field which is going
to be the gradient vector field at the
current point
and so if i do this discretization i get
the algorithm called mirror descent
and of course when
things are nice so when h is euclidean
then that primal space is our d with
this euclidean metric the dual space is
the same space with the euclidean metric
and this whole thing just becomes
gradient descent so in some sense mirror
descent well not in some sense it is a
generalization
of gradient descent although i suppose
there are many generalizations so
yes this is is it yes
uh so i just got lost for a second i
just wanna yes yes please slow me down
thank you
so you said that mirror descent is uh
natural gradient flow on the um
on the the you know the end of this map
and
the function that you're
yeah so okay uh one
thing to keep in mind so it's
i have two spaces
i have x
i have a dual
[Music]
and i'm taking this mapping uh grad h
but the inverse of this mapping
to map it out sorry i called these both
x this is z to map an element z back
into x
that's given by the gradient of this
central dual function
so
these two things are acting as inverses
of each other
so the statement is that the gradient
flow that natural gradient flow on x
when mapped under this mapping becomes
mirror flow this
dynamical system over here
i can discretize this in the primal
space and i get natural gradient descent
i can discretize this over here and i
get what's called mirror descent
so that's
hopefully more in words what's going on
that picture that's being painted
but of course this distinction kind of
collapses when
when h is uh the clean norm because this
becomes the identity map here
um
so x is being mapped to x
the gradient of that is just x okay so
hopefully things compute
support wonderful the obvious advantage
that you don't have to invest a question
when you do their research
if i were to not pay for any of this but
they have the same guarantees or there's
an example where there's a substantial
yeah so they're
the picture isn't as clear typically we
do have a lot of guarantees for meredith
in fact some mere descent behaves almost
exactly the same as great and descent
natural gradient descent is a little bit
different and the reason for that is the
following um
okay
so
uh
let's think about gradient descent
or gradient flow so we have this
dynamical system
and we have
uh let's say some sort of
function this optimality gap we're
trying to optimize
if i look at the time derivative of this
that's the gradient of f at x t
times
the
x t dot so that's going to be
negative gradient uh f of x t so it's a
distance flow
natural gradient descent
has this has this feature where this
vector field is given by natural
gradient descent what i'll get sorry
this should be squared
uh what i get is this uh with the
hessian metric
right
but mirror descent doesn't have that
very similarly if we look at the
distances as of the distance as this
kind of descending factor
uh
it behaves nicely so the distance we'll
be working with is a bregman distance
which i haven't really quite gotten to
but a lot of proofs of mere descent
feature this bregman divergence as
something that's contracting that's
dissipating
and this
matches well with mirror descent and not
as well with natural gradient distance
so these two things actually are are a
little bit different and it's exposed by
uh
the fact that
this is a dual algorithm something is
going on
having to do with this distance function
and this is the primal algorithms making
the function descend
right so the difference is not just in
the discrimination it's also in the
independence but you know in the
continuous one i can like they're
equivalent right so i mean morally
speaking if i have this
ode
i can also write this as
the mirror descent ode ddt
of
grad
t x t is equal to the negative gradient
direction
so these two formulations are they're
the same ode
so
the continuous time distinction because
i can write it both ways doesn't really
show up i can plug in both values but
when i discretize then all of a sudden
there is a difference there and what's
required of h to bound that error term
it might be slightly different between
the two
so
um but
you know i don't pretend to have the
full story in discrete time someone who
works on this like you know sebastian
blue back somebody can please hopefully
inform the crowd or leave a comment if
this is
posted somewhere about
about the difference in discrete time
yes you already mentioned distances um
so this very decent looks a bit like a
generalized version of fragment
iterations of bregman brilliant
algorithms can you comment a little bit
of the relations there yeah in fact i
think that'll be two slides
um and if it doesn't come up in two
slides uh please pick me but i think
what you're referring to is what's
coming up in two slides
um
so i think hopefully this is what you
meant by this so um
there are the discretizations as i
mentioned that you can take of these
odes
um i had mentioned what's called the the
the forward oiler
or the explicit euler method where i
evaluate the vector field at x k but if
i evaluated discretize this by
evaluating the vector field at x k plus
one
what i get is called the proximal
breakdown method
and that proximal begma method can be
can be written in the following form
it's just uh
establishing that xk plus 1 is the
argument of this this potential so this
the function value plus this bregman
distance
so this is actually a generalization of
the proximal mapping i had introduced in
part one of the talk
is this what you were referring to when
you mentioned uh bregman yeah
the explicit discretization i did before
absolutely absolutely so what he's
saying is mirror descent
can be written as if i um instead of
minimizing the function minimize the
inner product between the gradient at xk
and x
then this is just mirror descent but i
just decided to write it in this dual
format so it can be written in many ways
both of them can be written using
bregman distances so
these bregman distances show up
a lot when we're talking about these
dual discretizations
uh for both for both of these
um
so i just wanted to have one word about
bregman projections or this proximal
bregman uh method and bregman
projections in general so it's possible
to do all the things we talked about
involving constraints a little bit more
generally using dragon distances that's
kind of the punch line here
um and then i just want to give you a
somewhat illustration of why this all
matters so
sometimes the correct or oftentimes if
you
if you do something in the right
geometry it can make a significant
difference for convergence
so the first thing i do want to mention
though is that this bregman projection
we can define an uh
a generalized version of the projection
operator via the following uh
minimization problem
so instead of minimizing this euclidean
norm
i can minimize this bregman divergence
and again there's this nice relationship
between this proximal
bregman mapping and the bregman
projection namely that if my function is
the indicator of the set
then this proximal thing is equivalent
to the bregman projection
as
this non-expansive aspect this this kind
of uh
triangle inequality we had it's the
euclidean distance also holds for the
bregman distance so
in some sense all these things are
there's just more general descriptions
because we can move slightly to more
abstract spaces
so the question is how far can we push
these concepts so a lot of things follow
through or hold when we move into
hessian manifolds can we move into
further abstract spaces and hopefully my
the next two speakers will
will shed light on these kinds of
questions but
a lot of things do map nicely for
hessian manifolds
um and finally the the the algorithm i
just wanted to feature is this
projective mirror to send algorithm
it's written in in you know a certain
format but i could write it via a
bregman distance again
um and it's just simply the update where
i have this that would have been a mere
descent step but i just simply project
that using the bregman
uh projection operator
onto my set x prime and that's my new
iterate
so
all these things commutes with euclidean
spaces you can just define it a little
bit more generally here
and yeah small remark about dissipating
quantities
typically all you know we were talking
about
dissipating quantities being a nice
organizing principle for how we analyze
a lot of iterative methods and
optimization
um those same discipline dissipating
quantities
hold for these more general spaces
typically we just replace euclidean
distances
with bregman divergences
hard to drink water the coveted time so
that's unfortunate
sorry about that
um
a simple example that maybe you can
check for yourself if you're all
interested in checking your intuition is
um
this distance this quantity here uh
which would appear in gradient descent
does dissipate for smooth
functions when h is one strongly come
back so
this would normally be a euclidean
distance i replace it with a bregman
divergence and this thing dissipates
from mirror descent so mirror descent
has this really nice technology to it
there are tons of energy functions of
dissipating quantities we can associate
with these algorithms
so for the last
slide
i wanted to give an example that i
actually
took from a recent work by boy
john duchy or stephen boyd john duchy
and merc blanche out at stanford
and they
showed that for some
certain classes of problems and i mean
many people have showed things like this
but for certain classes of problems the
geometry can make a huge difference so
here's this robust regression problem
it's an lp
and we have this constraint set which is
the simplex
so i have this lp defined over the
simplex
and here they've just constructed uh an
instance of this
by by just kind of some certain
approximations
and then they plotted the performance of
the subgradient method where you use the
euclidean norm versus that subgraded
method where you use the the bregman
projection
and you can see there is a significant
significant difference
so using
the gi or kind of paying attention to
the geometry of the space you're
optimizing over
can make a big difference when it comes
to optimum optimizing your function so
it is really nice that we're having this
workshop so hopefully we'll learn a lot
more about this and you know we'll all
start deriving methods that will
solve our problems
okay so
with that i'll pause and i'll take
questions but that's pretty much what i
wanted
uh to say and i really thank you for
your attention
[Applause]
yes
so i had two follow-up questions after
your
nice explanation about you know
sometimes a
downside potential downside of
acceleration one is uh could you say
anything about the methods used in
practice to estimate the condition
number and second
for the the last example you were
talking about for the mirror gradient
scent um it is
i'm just trying to understand uh you
know how one would be choosing the h
would be what is one intentionally
trying to choose the h to get a better
condition number
um
or i guess yeah could you show me a
little bit about fun i'll take it into a
first quarter
so in some sense
oftentimes the best hd is the function
itself that would be newton's method
right or i mean not the mere descent but
the primal form of it natural gradient
descent with where h is f is just
newton's method that is
really nice because it does uh we have
found invariant that gives you really
really nice properties
um so there is something to be said for
choosing the right h
to do
optimization on and for statistical
manifolds entropy turns out to be a
really really nice thing to use and
often if you do
are working on simplexes or anything
like that that would be the natural
thing so
um but i don't know if i have or i'm
aware of a formal optimality statement
with regard to how to choose h if
anybody here knows of one that would be
lovely to hear
i would learn quite a bit but
i'm not quite sure
uh there's any
anybody who knows
so the question is if you have uh space
and i'm going to do some sort of
romanian descent or on a hessian
manifold how do i choose h
what is the optimal way of choosing h
such that i i converge quickly
yeah that could be i mean hopefully
we'll have more discussions about that
um
furthermore for the for the question
about the conditioning of the problem uh
there are a lot of
there is some work i'm aware of that
targets choosing l and oftentimes you
know
one over two l is the nicer one over l
is a nice thing but we do line searches
when we can maybe not for stochastic
methods but even for stochastic methods
people have recently tried to propose
some form some kinds of line searches so
um
unclear that you need to know l exactly
um
i am going to be omitting someone's work
in this so hopefully you can again leave
a comment and and
answer this for me uh with regard to
how to optimally or how to estimate l
some of the the nice ways of doing that
uh the condition so the the strong
convexity constant is actually a bit
harder to estimate so
in the context of acceleration what
people do is this thing called adaptive
restarting so
whether people observe that when you hit
a period where you're not
choosing the appropriate damping term in
a strongly convex setting you tend to
oscillate really quickly and what they
do
is they just restart the algorithm
that's one way of handling oscillation
perhaps to not knowing the problem
parameters
i'm not quite sure
and yeah gradient descent that you don't
need to know you you just need to
uh in the stochastic setting you do you
might need to know b but just one over l
is the setting the step size
um
that's that's kind of
my knowledge here but again i would i
would really appreciate learning more
about how people do solve this problem
so if anyone has work or nose of work
please please discuss
of course
all right so i guess now is the time for
a a break until uh 2pm and we're going
to resume with those two thoughts but i
think i said again great